[Applaus]
[Musik]
ich werde dir eine kleine frage stellen
und nein auch wikipedia nachschlagen
zählt nicht also kannst du dir sagen was
die währung el salvadors ist nun die
offizielle wäre deshalb teurer ist der
us dollar ja genau seit 2001 dem es soll
das gesetzliche zahlungsmittel des
zentralamerikanischen landes ab
september 2021 js halber da jedoch
offizielle zwei währungen haben den us
dollar und den bitcoin ja du hast
richtig gehört eltern war dort hat
gerade den bitcoin als gesetzliches
zahlungsmittel zugelassen und was
bedeutet das genau nun du kannst steuern
in wird kommen die zahlen und alle
unternehmen sind verpflichtet ist als
zahlungsmittel zu akzeptieren
und ich weiß was viele von euch denken
besonders diejenigen von euch die fans
von flugbewegungen sind wie war er
präsident der ihk
koffer packen und in diesem land des
fortschritts leben aber jetzt mal nicht
so schnell schau dir wird erst mal
dieses video bis zum ende an und
entscheidet dann ob du wirklich einen
oneway ticket nach san salvador buchen
möchte ist denn wenn es ein problem gibt
dass viele lateinamerikanische länder
gemeinsam haben dann ist es die währung
el salvador scheint sich dieser probleme
jedoch nicht wirklich bewusst zu sein
und warum nun weil sie einfach den
dollar benutzen die weinende frage ist
also was hat vogue elle dazu bewegt
bitcoins im gesetzlichen zahlungsmittel
zu erheben
wird es hat wirklich das paradies der
krypto währungen werden oder ist jedes
gesetze mit denen diese entscheidung
umgesetzt werden soll in wirklichkeit
ein trojanisches pferd wollte wären wir
diese fragen hier auf diese politik
beantworten aber lasst uns dazu erstmal
einen ganz schnellen blick in die
geschichte werfen
[Musik]
mittel bitcoin einwerfen was ist der
hauptunterschied zwischen einer crypto
währung und normalen geld nun normales
geld auch fiat geld genannt wird von den
banken in zusammenspiel mit den
zentralbanken geschaffen zum beispiel
kontrollieren die us federal reserve fed
oder die europäische zentralbank ezb die
geldmenge von dollar beziehungsweise
euro bitcoin und die meisten crypto
währungen sind eine ganz andere
geschichte bitcoin wurde 2009 von
satoshi nakamoto geschaffen ein
pseudonym dass die wahre identität
seines schöpfers verbirgt mit kohle
basiert auf der blog technologie wie
diese im detail funktioniert ist ein
thema für ein anderes video der wichtige
punkt ist das bitcoin eine währung ist
bei der es keine notwendigkeit für
geschäftsbanken oder starten gibt sie zu
retten hier
und genau dieser aspekt ist eines der
wichtigsten dinge anbieten da steht
nicht unter der aufsicht eines staates
oder einer regierung das heißt es gibt
niemanden der das angebot an bitcoins
kontrolliert theoretisch wird es eine
begrenzte anzahl von bitcoins in der
weltwirtschaft geben 21 millionen wird
kommt wenn diese zahl erreicht ist
werden keine weiteren mehr geschaffen
und was ist der vorteil davon ist
verhindert dass irgendein herrscher der
gerade an der macht ist die geldmenge
manipulieren kann das soll also seinen
wert als währung stabilität verleihen
aber das ist natürlich nur die theorie
denn die realität sieht so aus nun sind
2021 bitcoin traktiert die anleger mit
einem eindruck und einer rally von 30
prozent am selben tag die realität ist
nun mal das der bitcoins stärker
schwankt als die anzeige auf wasser groß
war deswegen nutzt ihn fast niemand als
wirkliches zahlungsmittel
wenn du also in den usa oder der eu lebt
ist es einfach viel bequemer und
praktikabler mit dollar oder euro zu
bezahlen und ich weiß was da jetzt durch
den kopf geht die jungs von visual
politik sind total gegen crypto
währungen voreingenommen richtig nur
nicht ganz ich habe meine ersten
bitcoins schon 2011 auf einen alten
notebook gemeint das war damals
wenigstens noch schön umweltfreundlich
und ganz ohne in island lebens müssen
wobei das sich ja auch schön ist aber in
der tat gibt es einen ort auf der welt
an denen der bitcoin tatsächlich
interessant sein könnte gesprächen über
lateinamerika
ja genau das ist ja kontinentes nahm man
in einem atemzug mit hyperinflation
nennt welches villa zum beispiel hat
inflationsraten von mehr als 100.000
prozent erreicht und es ist beileibe
nicht das einzige land das noch unter
hyperinflation gelitten hat in brasilien
und nicaragua galoppierte diese vor ein
paar jahrzehnten die einer folge von
wild werden und lässt aus argentinien
nicht vergessen 19-mal 2021 inflation
nahe 50 prozent bringt argentinien auf
einen weg das zuvor gescheitert ist
warum also hat lateinamerika so viel
hyperinflation der hauptgrund ist dass
die zentralbanken die währung nach
belieben manipulieren anders ausgedrückt
sie werfen die gelddruckmaschine an als
ob es kein morgen gäbe das führt dazu
dass die währung und weniger wert sind
als monopoly geld die idee einer währung
zu benutzen die nicht von einer
regierung oder zentralbank kontrolliert
wird muss also wie musik in den ohren
der geplagten südamerikaner klären 22
der juni 2021 während sich wenn es
fehler us wirtschaft zurück entwickelt
führt crypto die lücke da die du dir
vorstellen kannst ist es ganz logisch
dass die venezolaner wirklich alles dem
bolivar vorziehen würden die frage
lautet aber warum sie bitten deshalb hat
dort verwenden wollen immerhin wird in
diesem land der dollar als auch der
regierung verwendet die inflation also
im zaum gehalten warum also haben sie
sich dafür entschieden auf den äckern zu
setzen genau das werden wir jetzt
herausfinden
lokales große idee des alfa deutschland
einen millennial präsidenten heiko
keller ist der neue rock star der
lateinamerikanischen politik obwohl
viele denken dass er ein aufstrebender
thorandt ist gesprächen darüber
ausführlich in einem anderen video das
wirklich bizarre ist nur dass kehle in
seinen politischen plänen und programmen
den bitcoin nie erwähnt habt doch dann
wurde das überraschend und wie aus dem
nichts bei einer bitkom konferenz in
miami dieses video von präsident böge
ausgestrahlt nächste woche werde ich
einen gesetzentwurf an den kongress
schicken der bitcoin zu einem legalen
zahlungsmittel in el salvador machen
wird kurzfristig wird dies arbeitsplätze
schaffen und das vor beitragen dass
tausende außerhalb der formellen
wirtschaft finanzielle inklusion
erfahren
natürlich war danach in el salvador die
hölle los und nichts anderem mehr die
rede alles sei in der schwebe denn die
einzige offizielle ankündigung war
dieses video auch noch auf englisch das
in miami ausgestrahlt worden war kein
offizieller erklärte den menschen
deshalb war dort irgendwas und nur drei
tage später präsentierte die regierung
das bitcoin gesetzt dass innerhalb
weniger stunden vom parlament
verabschiedet wurde wir reden hier von
einem gesetz das 16 artikel hat ein
video skript bei visual politik kann da
schon bis zu viermal so lang werden
[Musik]
und setzt diese 16 artikel sind sehr
oberflächlich gehalten und gehen kaum
ist detail aber es gibt einige
interessante dinge darin zum beispiel
wird es möglich sein steuern mit
bitcoins bezahlen und nein die
salvatorianer werden dabei keine
vorreiter sein denn seit monaten
akzeptiert der schweizer kampf und zog
die zahlung von steuern mit bitkom und
isar wenn es jedoch einen wirklich
bahnbrechenden wie kontroversen punkten
mit comics gibt dann ist ist artikel
jeder wirtschaftsteilnehmer muss mit con
als zahlungsmittel akzeptieren wenn dies
von denjenigen angeboten wird der eine
ware oder dienstleistung erwirbt artikel
7 des grundgesetzes von 2021 diesen
artikel scheint ist klar zu sein dass
die server oriana gezwungen sein werden
bitkom zu akzeptieren ob sie wollen oder
nicht und zunächst schien dies auch
präsident lokale selbst zu bestehen wenn
eine frau auf dem markt obst verkauft
ist sie verpflichtet die bezahlung in
bitcoin anzunehmen
irgendwie ist es dann aber problematisch
wenn man erst zwei wochen nach der
verabschiedung des bitkom gesetzes damit
anfängt zu erklären was es eigentlich
bedeutet und was ist nicht bedeutet und
das auch noch in einem portalen gaga
stil
nun ja es scheint dass jeder
verpflichtet ist mit kann als
zahlungsmittel zu akzeptieren so mit
bitcoins zu erhalten aber das ist nicht
der fall wirtschaftsakteure zum beispiel
händler sind verpflichtet konzept ihn
aber nicht sie zu empfangen
also ist man doch nicht dazu gezwungen
aber warte artikel 8 ist noch
interessanter er besagt dass du in
bitkom mit hilfe privater wolle es
zahlen kannst aber dass der staat
alternativen bereitstellen wird die
transaktion in bitcoin ermöglicht was
bedeutet das nun im grunde das bouquet
de eine staatliche wallet geschaffen hat
und mit bitcoins zu operieren sie wird
timo heißen und an dieser stelle fängt
die ganze geschichte schon arg zu
knirschen denn eine der prämissen von
crypto währungen wie bitcoin ist doch
dass sie dezentral also außerhalb der
reichweite von regierungen funktionieren
soll ganz zu schweigen von einem anderen
thema das auch nicht besonders
vertrauenserweckend ist denn wenn es
eine sache gibt mit der pokale die
wahlen gewonnen hat dann dass er sich
den menschen als verfechter von
transparenz des kampfes gegen die
korruption präsentiert hat ein
verfechter der es ihnen erlauben würde
die skandale der vorhergehenden den
regierungen zu vergessen doch alles an
der tchibo wollen erinnert zu sehr
hatten die schlechten praktiken der
vergangenheit lokale imitiert fmln und
vergibt mit con projekt direkt
unmittelbar das heißt ohne öffentliche
ausschreibung bieterverfahren oder
sonstiges hat die entwicklung der tchibo
wollte vollkommen eigenmächtig us
unternehmens namens strike vergeben aber
wartet einen moment das bitcoin gesetz
birgt noch weitere fallen denn nach dem
was wir jetzt zeigen werden sollten sich
bitkom fans wirklich noch mal überlegen
ob sich tatsächlich nach el salvador
auswandern sollten um dort ihren traum
vom alltäglichen leben mit ihrer
lieblings strukturierung genießen zu
können
[Musik]
kleingedruckte des bitkom gesetzes weißt
du was die haupteinnahmequelle es ist
geldüberweisungen aus dem ausland ja ein
viertel der salvadorianer etwa zwei
millionen menschen leben im ausland die
meisten von ihnen in den vereinigten
staaten all diese ausland salvadorianer
schicken ihren familien regelmäßig geld
damit diese in der heimat über die
runden kommen über wichtige treten wir
hier genau nun nicht weniger als sechs
milliarden dollar pro jahr das sind 20
prozent des bip es aber doch und das ist
so viel wie die gesamte export leistung
des landes die austrianer nutzen hierbei
die überweisung des dienstes für
unternehmen wie western union und
moneygram natürlich bieten diese
unternehmen diesen service nicht umsonst
an fußballern provision
der punkt ist nun laut also dem ok lass
dich salvadorianischen bürgern von
profitieren würden wenn sie bitcoins
stadt dollars für überweisungen
verwenden da dies billiger wäre wo liegt
also das problem darin dass das im
grunde bullshit ist die daten beweisen
immer wieder das gegenteil denn
interessanterweise hat es war durch eine
der niedrigsten provisions raten für
geldüberweisungen weltweit um die reine
vorstellung zu geben der durchschnitt in
lateinamerika liegt bei 5,6 prozent
liegt er bei 2,85 prozent behalten diese
zahlen hinterkopf 2,85 prozent und wie
viel kostet es dollar bitcoins zu
wechseln nun das unternehmen das die
meisten bitcoin automaten im land hat
heißt athena diese firma besteht eine
provision von 5% und du fragst dich
jetzt vielleicht wieso denn das
interesse an bitcoin so groß ist
nur hier kommt eine mögliche erklärung
die regierung und el salvador kann über
die internationale geldüberweisungen
normalerweise keine kontrolle ausüben
sie weise weder wie viel geld genau an
kommt noch kann sie diese besteuern wie
wird es aber sein wenn diebe weisungen
in bitkom ankommen stell dir vor du
schickst bitcoins an jemanden in es
faktor der eine regierung wollen hat
diese ballett gehört der regierung sie
hat dann die volle kontrolle über den
zahlungsverkehr aber ich weiß was du
jetzt einwenden dass man kann doch
einfach ein relatives privates wolle
dass das der regierung benutzen und
schon ist man aus dem schneider und an
dieser stelle kommt das kleingedruckte
des gesetzes ins spiel und die dinger
werden sehr sehr schwammig er ist halber
teure mittel zum umtausch von bitkom den
dollar würden nicht ausreichen aber
lasst zurückzog bitcoin gesetz gehen
sein artikel 17 besagt dass der staat
die automatische und sofortige
konvertierbarkeit von bitkom den dollar
garantieren wird solange du seine worte
benutzt das heißt sie wollen aber warte
einen moment denn da ist noch mehr hier
kommt artikel 9 des gesetzes und steht
in diesem artikel er spricht über
einschränkungen der automatischen
konvertierung alternativen mit anderen
worten dass die regierung die nutzung
einer anderen welt als der staatlichen
schiebold ganz einfach verbieten kann
zwar sind diese restriktionen zurzeit
noch nicht in einer verordnung umgesetzt
aber wenn die regierung ist will sie
dieses jahr jeder zeit in kraft setzen
und warum sollten sie die verwendeten
worts einschränken wollen nun die
regierung hat einen fonds in höhe von
150 millionen dollar geschaffen und
umwandlung von bitcoin in dollar zu
garantieren das problem ist was würde
passieren wenn es nicht den ansturm
darauf losbrechen würde bitkom den
dollar umtauschen was würde passieren
wenn dieser völlig erschöpft ist nun die
wahrheit ist dass das niemand weiß und
vokale scheint mit anderen dingen
beschäftigt zu sein
ok präsident von el salvador bekommt
laser augen auf twitter um bitcoins zu
unterstützen und immer wenn jemand eine
solche manipulativ innovative show
abzieht muss man aufpassen und sich
fragen welche agenda eigentlich wirklich
dahinter steckt also hintergrund ist der
folgende ok hat die staatsausgaben
massiv in die höhe getrieben ohne die
einnahmen also steuer soll will das wäre
ja unpopulär das land braucht aber
händeringend dollars um seine schulden
zu tilgen der deal auf nun mal in us
dollars diese könnten ganz zufällig
auslandsüberweisungen kommen während die
bürger bitcoins erhalten die
salvadorianer stecken jetzt in einer
zwickmühle wenn sie nicht die rolle der
regierung nutzen müssen sie alle risiken
des direkten bitcoin besitzers meistern
also die hohe volatilität die langen
transaktions zeiten und die hohen
produktionskosten und das ist für eine
normale marktfrau die ihr geld täglich
als zahlungsmittel braucht um überhaupt
zu überleben der blanke horror und ja
ich weiß das ist workarounds wie das
network mit dem versucht wird dieses
problem zu fixen aber damit war das
problem nur verlagert und eigentlich
wieder so was wie einen bankensystem
durch die hintertür eingeführt
[Musik]
für die allermeisten besteht also von
anfang an ein sehr starker anreiz die
staatliche wolle zu nutzen und natürlich
musst du wenn du die regierungsrolle
benutzt weil die vorschriften beachten
die ihre nutzung eingrenzen denn noch
bevor alle dollars des umtauschs
verbraucht sind wird es zu einer
korrektur situation kommen in der der
umtausch ganz einfach begrenzt wird okay
da hat er somit geschafft die
ursprünglichen ideale der bitcoin
erfinder in der genau das gegenteil zu
verkehren
er hat den beweis geliefert dass man
genau jedes zahlungsmittel wer ist
eigentlich dafür gedacht war die
unabhängigkeit der menschen vor staat
und seiner geld manipulationsgerüchte zu
erhöhen perfekt dazu missbrauchen kann
um die abhängigkeit noch weiter zu
erhöhen ja es ist schon eine ironie des
schicksals das ist wohl gerade der
truppe um ist siege herrscher eines
armen unbedeutende lange sind in
mittelamerika als derjenige in die
geschichte eingehen wird der den
genannten der kultur währungen gezaubert
hat aber ok hat noch ein anderes
drängendes problem zu lösen el salvadors
schulden könnten 100 prozent des bip
erreichen so de cv die schulden des
landes betragen bereits mehr als 90
prozent des bruttoinlandsprodukts mit
anderen worten warum sollten sie nicht
einfach eine steuer einführen um von den
überweisungen zu profitieren und jetzt
kommt noch eine ganz andere dimension
endspiel wenn die salvatorianer angst
tragen ihre bitcoin in dollar zu
tauschen und auch ihre steuern in
bitcoin zu bezahlen wird das
salvadorianische staat plötzlich im
besitz einer riesigen menge bitcoins
seien wiederum mit allen risiken welche
das mit sich bringt lokales entscheidung
könnte den staat reich machen wenn der
mitte steigt aber sie könnte ihn auch
endgültig in den ruin treiben sinkt
lokale hat el salvador somit zu einem
großen bitcoins locker gemacht und in
diesem fall lautet die große frage dann
nämlich die es hat darüber mit seinen
auslandsschulden umgehen und wie seine
gläubiger ratingagenturen und die
internationalen investoren darauf
reagieren werden die rückzahlung ihrer
staatsanleihen hängt es nämlich am
schicksal des bitkom und viele werden
sich alles andere als begeistert davon
sein sie haben schließlich in
staatsanleihen investiert weil sie ihr
geld stabil anlegen und nicht von
magischen internet münzen abhängig sein
wollen und ich fürchte dass wir in den
kommenden monaten noch einiges über
dieses thema hören werden aber für den
moment ist die frage jetzt an dich
gerichtet heißt du bist entscheidung gut
oder zu riskant würdest du dir wünschen
dass sein land mit kommen ebenfalls als
gesetzliches zahlungsmittel einführt und
denkst du dass kings rezepte der
staatlichen kontrolle über
zahlungsströmen mit hilfe des bitkom
überall auf der welt nachahmer dämpfen
könnte teilt eure meinung bitte wir
immer mit uns und auch ein anderer im
kommentarbereich ich hoffe dass euch
dieses video gefallen hat was ja gibt es
gleich teilt es mit euren freunden und
vergesst nicht unseren kanal auch zu
abonnieren macht's gut und bis bald
[Musik]